ما الذي يتعين عليك القيام
به في المدينة ، ما نوع التغييرات التي يتعين
عليك إجراؤها في
حالة حدوث غزو تم
كسره
قبل ستة أشهر ، بدأنا في إعداد
المدينة لحالة طارئة ، على
سبيل المثال كيفية توفير المياه بدون
كهرباء ونحن قادرون  من خلال القيام بذلك اليوم ،
ضاعفنا احتياطياتنا من الإمدادات الطبية ثلاث مرات ،
ونزيد احتياطيات الدم ،
ونعيد ترتيب عمل جميع
مؤسساتنا الإستراتيجية ،
نحن مستعدون اليوم لعيش الحياة في ظل
ظروف قاسية ، ماذا
سيفعل شعب ليف إذا غزا الروس كيف
سيكون رد فعلهم
أولاً ، يتم تطوير
الدفاع الإقليمي
بنشاط ليس فقط في ليفي ولكن
في جميع مدن أوكرانيا
في المجموع ، هناك ما يقرب من
مليوني شخص
يتعلمون كيفية استخدام الأسلحة
وتقديم المساعدة الطبية ، هذا بلدنا
ويجب علينا حمايته  أنفسنا